[Musique]
des sardes à queue jaune des corps ou
des éponges une faune riche
représentatif de toute la côte caraïbe
nous sommes dans la commune du carbet au
lieu-dit le résigner
[Musique]
la zone connu par les amateurs de
plongée grâce à l'épave du navire la
moby s'étend sur une surface de nectar
et commence tout juste à retrouver des
couleurs
une forte baisse de fréquentation de la
zone là on commence à observer
une vo population mais très lente très
faibles donc pour le moment la zone et
dix ans en train de guérir tout petit à
petit et le but c'est de laisser guérir
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit complètement
rétabli des panneaux de signalisation
des coffres d'amarrage pour protéger cet
espace même dispositif pour la zone du
pot thiou situe entre la pointe marouba
et lapointe potier ici aussi toutes les
formes de pêche sont désormais
interdites mais également l'ancrage des
bateaux les infractions peuvent être
lourdes un cd infractions qui peuvent
être pénales devant le juge jean de
grande instance où ça peut être des
infractions administratives des
sanctions administratives sanctions
administratives ça peut aller jusqu'à
1500 euros d'amendé amendes et des
suspensions permis ou des choses comme
ça donc oui c'est bien protégés voilà
une cote ciselés par le temps des décors
à couper le souffle
le pous-tio est redevenu fréquentable et
bénéficie même de suivi scientifique
depuis le balisage la vie sous marine
est de retour et les marins pêcheurs
peuvent aussi ils trouvent leur intérêt
soins qu'il faut protéger la zone pur
produit de cette espèce de poisson moi
je suis d'accord
suivront six pour l'avenir donc vous
l'avenir de mes enfants et ados que si
il fallait versable on a fait ce coup
j'ai de protection de l'air marine du
carpe est en gestation depuis 20 ans est
à l'initiative de michel métairie le
compagnon du commandant cousteau à
l'installation technique des bruits et
du balisage a été possible grâce à des
financements publics et privés nous
avons reçu une subvention fait
gratification de madame ségolène royal
qui est devenu lourd mais il faut dire
aussi d'être remercié les partenaires
tous les partenaires privés qui
s'investit qui s'investit dans ce
magnifique chantier est donc
effectivement ça a coûté mais les
partenaires ont amené monsieur plus ce
qui manque
[Musique]
la ville du carbet plus que jamais
engagée dans un développement durable a
été récompensé par la palme de l'ihf
record une distinction qui récompense
les initiatives de protection du milieu
marin dans la caraïbe la faune du
résinier et du petit on commence tout
juste à renaître mais devra résister aux
événements qui fleurissent de plus en
plus sur l'eau dont le tour des lions